- Okay, hi, everybody, welcome.
We're gonna get started.
My name is Daniel Martinez HoSang.
I'm a faculty member in
Ethnicity, Race, and Migration.
I can't just tell you how amazing it is
to see on a brutally cold afternoon,
how great it is, and the
warmth that we sense in here,
for this really, really
important conversation.
I'm gonna just do, and I'm gonna moderate,
I'll introduce our speakers in a moment,
but just start by a
couple of the, you know,
there's a lot, a lot of work
that went into pulling this
off in just a couple of days.
So, we first wanna thank our colleagues
in the Yale Education Studies Program,
and especially the Director Mira Debs,
who just worked tirelessly.
(audience applauding)
I'll introduce in a moment
our colleague Paul Van
Tassel from the Senate.
But a lot of this, I mean,
this event is sponsored principally
by the Yale Faculty Senate,
and it means an enormous amount
that our colleagues across
many, many departments
and programs and schools
understand that when we're saying
there's something very,
very serious happening
in our discipline and in our world,
that they respond to that call,
and wanna know more about it,
and wanna know how they can be engaged.
So we're grateful to
the Yale Faculty Senate,
to the Gilder Lehrman Center,
the Anti-Racist Teaching
and Learning Collective,
and the many teachers who
are involved with that.
African American Studies,
my colleague Jason Stanley,
and of course, the African
American Policy Forum.
So, just first, please join me
in thanking all of our co-sponsors.
(audience applauding)
I'll also just say, you know,
our aspiration here is
to listen to one another,
to learn from one another.
I imagine anyone that had any shady plans
to disrupt this event would
find it too cold to be outside
(audience laughing)
and then make their way here.
But we're looking forward
to generative exchanges
that can help us all become
sharper thinkers and actors.
Okay, so with that, I wanna
invite my colleague, Paul,
to come up and just say a few words
on behalf of the Yale Faculty Senate,
and then we'll get into our panel.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Professor HoSang.
It's just, I'm delighted to be here today
to lead the Senate this year,
and to help sponsor such an event.
The Senate stands fully behind
promoting these types of events
where we engage in dialogue,
we listen to one another,
we learn from one another,
and especially when the room is so packed
that people can hardly sit.
So, again, I'm Paul Van Tassel.
I am a professor in Chemical
and Environmental Engineering
here at Yale.
This year I happen to be
chair of the Faculty Senate.
Maybe many of you are students,
you might not know we
have a Faculty Senate.
We do have a Faculty Senate.
It's a little bit like
your Yale College Council
or the Graduate Student Assembly.
It's the principal governing
structure of faculty
here at Yale University.
And we're excited about
a lot of our activities,
among them sponsoring
wonderful events like this.
And principle, maybe as
the single unifying topic
that we address as a senate
is this concept of academic freedom.
I think everybody knows,
I know students are here
from many different levels,
but academic freedom is
basically, as it sounds, right?
It's the freedom as a professor
to teach what we feel should be taught,
to research what we feel
should be researched
and engage in dialogue freely
and in debate freely about
what we feel is important.
The same principles hold for students too,
and other educators.
We feel, for me perhaps,
it's my most cherished aspect
of my job, is that I have the
freedom to do those things.
And today's topic strikes
really at the heart
of academic freedom.
The Senate among its other activities
recently has released a resolution
speaking against these so-called
educational gag orders.
It's a phenomena that goes
beyond just the discussion
that we'll have today,
but it encompasses the
discussion we'll have today.
And these have to do with legislations
that might act to
restrict academic freedoms
on various levels.
And so, again, we're very, very happy
to be able to sponsor
this important event.
And I should point out
too, that today's teaching,
no matter who was presenting,
this would be a very important topic
and one certainly worthy
of a nice discussion.
But in fact, in this case,
we have two individuals
that have been targeted
by such legislation.
So my own Yale colleague,
Roderick Ferguson,
and colleague of sorts, but from Columbia,
Kimberlé Crenshaw, who
themselves have been targeted,
and their academic freedom
has been put in jeopardy
at least potentially by
these types of legislation.
So with that,
again welcome everybody,
and I look forward to a great discussion.
(audience applauding)
- All right.
So I'm gonna do,
and I should also mention our colleague
Daisha Brabham, who is a member
of the anti-racist Teaching
and Learning Collective,
a brilliant teacher at
Windsor High School,
was not able to come today,
I suspect she's watching
on the livestream.
So, hi Daisha.
I'm gonna do my best to
incorporate some of the comments
that Daisha shared with us in advance.
I'm gonna say something very quick
to try to kind of get us on
the same page as best I can
about what's happened in
the last couple of weeks.
And then we're gonna do a
series of kind of rounds
to get each of the panelists
in conversation with one another.
What are they seeing, hearing, noticing?
What are the opportunities?
Throughout, there'll be a chance
for you to share your
questions for the panelists.
And the brilliant APF staff will help
to kind of curate them so that
we can engage your questions
at the end.
And then I think at 5:30,
we'll all be going upstairs
for the reception afterwards
and have a chance to talk.
Okay, so over the last 10
years, the College Board,
which is formally a nonprofit,
but is responsible for administering
all the standardized tests
that many students were
subjected to in this room,
as well as AP courses,
Advanced Placement courses,
which of course, are intended
to resemble college courses
and in many cases offer college credit
to develop a course in
African American studies.
The very fact that after
many, many decades,
the AP first decided
that it would be finally
appropriate to do this
is in effect of many,
many students and faculty
and scholars and advocates
demanding the inclusion of
these bodies of knowledge.
About two weeks ago, maybe a little more,
the governor of Florida, Ron DeSantis
and the Education Department announced,
there had been previous drafts circulated,
all AP courses are often
done in close collaboration
with college faculty who
are experts in their field
because they're intended to replicate
what a college course would be,
announced that the course
had no educational value
for Florida students.
And a day or two later released a graphic
trying to identify bodies of both scholars
and bodies of knowledge
that it said would not be taught
to Florida high school students
until the College Board revised that.
Among the scholars listed
were our colleagues
Professor Crenshaw, Professor
Ferguson, Bell Hooks,
Angela Davis.
Bodies of knowledge
including queer studies,
social movements, abolition, et cetera.
By some coincidence, three days
later, as the story unfolds,
the College Board announced
that in its revised curriculum,
all of those thinkers and bodies
of knowledge and many more
had now been moved to an optional section.
So they were effectively,
effectively students could
study them as essay topics
and for further discussion
and disavow that it was in any way related
to the earlier round of criticism.
And we'll talk about some
of the reasons they cited.
So here we are now today.
The College Board effectively signing off
on a kind of hiving off and
sanitizing of the curriculum
and thinking about what was at stake,
who was named in those exclusions,
and what the loss is and
how that reverberates.
So for the first round of
questions, I want to, hi, Kim.
- Hi.
- Welcome.
So, and Kim and the APF, of
course, have been crucial
since the attacks on
critical race theory began
three years ago now, I think.
That's right, in helping
us think about the link
between what's happening in
Florida, what a resolution
that we may be paying
attention to in Texas,
and kind of a broad set of concerns.
So I wanna ask each of you, and I'll just,
I'm gonna do these super quick.
Our colleague David Blight in history,
Jason Stanley in philosophy,
and Roderick Ferguson in
women and Gender Studies,
ERM and African American Studies.
It has been a whirlwind, just a whirlwind
from the time we started
planning this, right,
two other chapters have unfolded.
So I just wanna first start,
we're gonna get into the
analysis, the unpacking,
but I wanna get a sense of
what you've seen, right?
What, across all of this,
the headlines, the claims,
the indignities, what stood out to you,
and maybe just share a moment or, yeah,
something you read that
really kind of captures it.
So that'll be our first round,
and then we'll go from there.
And Kim, I'd love to start with you.
- All right.
Well, good afternoon, everyone.
When I heard about the weather,
I thought there'd be five people
here, so I am overwhelmed.
So, great to be here.
So I wanna talk about the headlines.
Because those are, those
are the things that
in my mind reinforce one of the problems
that we've been seeing for two years.
And that is the way the
media have functioned
somewhat as a third arm
in this effort to
politicize the university,
to demonize critical race theory,
intersectionality in particular,
and to create what in its best
moments is a both sides-ism,
but sometimes it doesn't
even arise to that level.
So here's one of the headlines
from the New York Times.
"DeSantis Takes on the
Education Establishment
"and Builds his Brand."
So let's just ponder
this for a moment, right?
This is, basically this could
come from the sports page,
you know, a general manager
of X and X team, you know,
acquires such and such,
and they're in line for the Super Bowl.
It's sort of treating
some of the most significant
challenges to our democracy
as a question of
branding, as a question of
is this going to be the strategy
that puts him into the White House?
You don't get a sense in this headline
that what we're looking at
is the attack on public education,
the attack on more than
70 years of building
a civil rights infrastructure
that's backed up by and
amplified by the kind of work
that people who are deeply invested
in addressing the history of this country
and its contemporary implications
for our current democracy.
You don't get a sense that
any of that is in there.
So for me, this is an illustration
of how what we're facing
is not just a coordinated, organized,
and well-funded campaign
on the part of those
who seek to make racism erasable,
those who seek to make Black history
basically end at 1960.
We're also fighting against a media
that's taken a kind of,
well, maybe/maybe not
kind of approach.
And now with the presidential campaign,
it's turning into more of the
sort of sports commentary.
I suggest that we think about
what some alternatives
might have been to that.
Maybe, you know, the war
against academic freedom
takes a victory, right?
The war is against us,
has gotten an important
victory under its belt.
Or Black studies is the next venue
in the war against academic freedom.
That would give you a
little bit more of a sense
of what is going on,
or maybe College Board and DeSantis align
in their blow to academic freedom.
Right, does that get
us a little bit closer?
Or how about this?
DeSantis unveils his
racially charged strategy
to the White House?
Maybe that gets us a little bit closer,
but I would say it just reinforced
how much the media is also
a site of contestation
in this moment.
- Yeah, isolated unfolding of events.
That's just a kind of
campaign curiosity, spectacle,
- Yes.
- To do that, right?
Okay, Rod, let's turn to you.
You know, I imagine you're,
I had just this thought
you were, I don't know,
getting ready to like, yeah,
I think you could just turn it, yeah.
- Jason wants his microphone.
You might have turned it off and on.
Can you hear me?
- Yeah, yeah.
- All right, good.
- Yeah, yes, so, Rod, you were
thrust in the middle of this.
I imagine like without much notice.
You wrote a brilliant piece
in the Chronicle of Higher Education,
which everyone should read.
What stands out to you?
- You know, first of all,
it's great to see everybody.
I see some of mine in the
room, former students,
so great to see all of
you and also colleagues.
I think that for me, it, you know,
the headlines that suggested
the sort of degrading
of critical thinking and
critical pedagogy, you know,
those were the things that stuck out.
So one headline is
"The College Board strips
down it's AP Curriculum
for African American Studies."
The official course looks
different from a previous draft,
no more critical race theory,
and the study of contemporary topics
like Black Lives Matter is optional.
So I used to teach writing, right?
That's how I cut my teeth.
And what's constructed,
what's implied in this headline
is that critical race
theory, Black Lives Matter,
all of the things that we associated
with contemporary struggles are excess.
You know, they don't belong.
They're not needed.
They're unnecessary.
And that we can do away with them, right?
At that moment, you
know, we have an assault,
not just on critical race theory.
We also have an assault
on critical pedagogy,
critical thinking, literacy.
That should alarm all of us.
You know, no matter
our disciplines, right?
There's a way in which, you know,
focusing on African American studies
makes it seem as if it's a special object,
a specialized target.
But this is actually a
pretty general assault
on all education and critical literacy.
So those are the things that
stood out for me as a teacher.
- Yeah, and there's such
an important move there
to kind of reduce a
course to simply content,
to simply mastering a body of content.
That's not a, that's
not just a subtle shift
in what's incorporated, right?
That's announcing what a class is for
and what it's not for.
- Right.
- And you sit there.
All right, Jason, all the way on the end
with your own microphone.
What did you see?
Yes, and I'll just say also,
Jason, you've, you know,
written a lot, obviously
about (all laughing).
Public goods.
Okay, about, you know,
currents of fascism,
which seems not another
time, another place,
how they show up, how
they shape these events.
So yeah, what stood out to you?
- So, two things stood out.
First, my work on fascism is based
in the Black intellectual tradition.
The way that theorists from
Langston Hughes to Angela Davis
to Toni Morrison have talked
about fascist practices
in the United States, like banning books,
restricting education.
And the person who has
taught me most about that
is my colleague, Rod
Ferguson, who was declared,
whose work was declared as
having no educational value.
So that's deliberate, to
declare the sources of education
as having no educational value.
That's intentional.
And the second thing
that really struck me,
just in terms of the
paradoxicality of it all,
was that Kimberlé Crenshaw
was coming to get the Winslow
medal at my university,
the highest medal given by
Yale School of Public Health
for concepts such as intersectionality,
which were being banned from
the curriculum in Florida
as having no educational value.
So no educational value means obviously
very high educational value.
(audience laughing)
- Thanks, Jason.
Professor Blight, you
know, a lot of your work
gives us a historic context
to understand moments
of revanchism, right?
Reclaiming something that seems lost,
from reconstruction,
the kind of national reunion
quote unquote that followed.
What did you see that caught your eye?
- First of all,
I've never used that fancy
word revanchism in print.
- [Daniel] It's yours.
- I need to think about that now.
First of all, amazing turnout.
Thank you all for, I see
a lot of my students,
former students, incredible.
Teach-ins are alive and well.
How about that?
Let me just describe what
I experienced this week.
You know, in a little chronology.
First of all, I agree the headlines
could be one hell of a lot better.
But here's what happened.
A week ago today I got an
email from David Coleman,
the head of the College Board
and two of his assistants
asking me to endorse
the course, The Course.
I said, well, fine, but
I'd like to read it first.
His initial point was that I
should just have confidence
in the people who are
the lead consultants.
Now those are good friends of mine,
but you still wanna read
something before you blurb it.
The next day, they sent me the course.
Turns out the course I
read is the final one
that they were about to
release on Wednesday.
The one with the excised
eight or 10 sections
from the last part.
I didn't know that.
On Monday I wrote an endorsement,
mostly about academic freedom.
I just said the usual things
about academic freedom.
I said, this is what this is about.
And I said something like, no
state legislature, governor,
or board of education has
any business messing in,
I didn't use the word messing,
but in course curriculum for
the public schools period.
And then that afternoon,
and let's give a little shout out here
to some people in the journalism world
who are actually trying to do their job.
My own student, Rose, are you here?
I don't know.
I can't tell.
She used to be editor of the Yale Daily.
She's now working for NBC News.
She gets me on the phone as
a person to be interviewed,
not as her senior essay
advisor, which I also am.
And Rose had the old version
that had been pirated out.
And you could get it finally
through the Wall Street Journal
and some other places.
I had the final version.
I didn't know there
was an earlier version.
And so on the phone for more than an hour,
Rose and I are comparing the two versions,
point by point by point.
And I thought, oh, uh
huh, this was all excised.
So I that afternoon
withdrew my endorsement
from Mr. Coleman.
He respectfully said, thank you.
I said, until I understand
what the hell happened here,
no endorsement.
Then I spent an hour
on the phone with Kim.
I think that night, I can't remember now,
just musing about what
the hell's going on.
I don't know.
What do you think's going on?
What about this, what about that?
We gossiped a lot
about who actually is
consulting on this thing.
And then one thing led
to another to another,
all kinds, you know, you get
quoted in one press piece,
and they all start calling you.
Last point about that,
I think it's yesterday,
I did an interview with a
guy from the Washington Post,
Nick Anderson, I think his name is,
he does higher ed for them.
He had gone out and interviewed
a whole bunch of people
who had worked on this
curriculum all through last year.
Teachers, professors, et cetera.
Some had just been asked to critique it.
Others had actually conceived it.
To a person, this was
information worth having,
to a person they said,
we were working on this all last year.
We were doing all this
long before DeSantis
ever said anything.
We're not doing this.
We didn't make changes.
You need to know this,
in response to DeSantis.
We made the changes for
substantive reasons.
Now this is what we can still debate.
What substantive reasons?
Why only the stuff at
the end of the course?
Why only the contemporary
stuff and so on and so forth.
But it's not like they just heard,
it's simply not true
that they heard DeSantis's
news conference last week
and suddenly made the changes.
That's just not true.
I also am keen to say,
and when we come back
to other topics here,
we're having this debate
on Ron DeSantis's terms,
and we need to think otherwise.
Now that's not easy because
they have millions of dollars
behind this campaign
against public schools.
They have Koch Brothers
money behind this campaign.
The educational community,
academia, teachers,
especially teachers
don't have big lobbies,
and they don't have
big propaganda budgets.
But we need a social movement
somehow tantamount to
the right wing's attack
on public schools to fight back
so that we can begin to
have a debate about this,
not just on Ron DeSantis's terms.
And I hope that's the last
time I used his name here.
- All right, well, thanks
for those initial snapshots.
I think they helped give
us a different, right,
putting together like a
different pieces of the puzzle
that people had accessed.
I actually want to pick
up then on something,
Professor Blight that you just said.
I think one of the
complexities of this decision
to offer what Professor Ferguson described
as a certain articulation
and version of the course
is that it allows the governor
and the Board of Education
to state that they are not
actually explicitly opposed
to teaching Black history
in Florida classrooms,
but that they have an obligation to ensure
that the content is, in their
words, educationally valuable.
So they're actually,
they have a kind of
disavowal at stake, right?
And it's also the case
that there have been
some prominent scholars
through different avenues
that have signed off
on this version of the course,
arguing that's either an
incremental opportunity
to introduce important
material to students
or that the content that was left out
was secondary to the curriculum.
And this gets to something,
David, that you said that,
that it was theory as opposed to history.
And so it's a kind of
non-ideological decision,
colorblind decision to privilege
some content over others.
So for the next round,
I wanted to think about
how you kind of unpack
and make sense of these
comments, these disavowals.
This has nothing to do with X.
What do they bring to mind for you?
What are the underlying
links between the scholars,
and I think this is really
important for us to think about,
the scholars named and
the sets of politics
and analytics and prisms that
were at stake in their work.
Because the official defense
is we had room for 40,
we had, you know, there were 60 there.
We just, this is a product of compromise.
It has no politics attached to it.
So I actually wanna just bring this back.
Let's start with you, David, a little bit
to think about the histories of disavowal.
What's familiar perhaps about this,
this sense that it has nothing
to do with the content,
with the political commitments
or with race and producing
racial knowledge itself?
- I have to go first this time?
It's more fun to go last,
but every time you hear somebody say
this is not about politics,
it's about politics.
I mean, it is.
In fact, that's what
this is ultimately about.
It is ultimately about the elimination
of Roderick and Kim's work
and that and Ta-Nehisi's
essay on reparations
and the unit on Black Lives Matter
and the other six or seven
items that were removed.
But this is a political discussion.
This is about power.
This is about who gets
to control education.
And it's way beyond education.
It's about who gets to
control the next election,
who gets to control legislatures.
So anytime they're, and the
idea that the College Board,
come on folks, and I actually,
there's a lot of good
people who work there.
They, I mean, you may not like
these AP tests and courses
and God help you, but, you know,
they work hard on these things.
It's also a billion dollar operation.
Let's remember that for a nonprofit.
But they are making political decisions.
It's really that simple.
Now this business of
what's a secondary source
and a primary source here
is a false distinction.
I mean, my goodness, your work is now,
it's a primary source.
Good lord.
I mean in a real sense it's become,
there are ways in which
what's written about something
in a time, in a moment becomes over time
its own kind of primary source.
I mean, when Dubois wrote the last chapter
of "Black Reconstruction,
the Propaganda of History,"
that was the last chapter
of black reconstruction.
That is now very much a primary source.
And I've been teaching it all my life.
Okay.
Does that mean I have two minutes?
Oh, cool.
But so that's just a false distinction,
and they made that up
in the absence of something else to say.
We just cut out secondary sources.
No, they didn't.
There are secondary sources
earlier in the course as well.
And by the way, there's a lot that's good
in those first three
quarters of this course.
They spend the first
five weeks of this course
on African civilizations,
African societies,
the origins of the African slave trade,
the beginnings of an African diaspora
and all of its enormous complexity.
How many American kids
know anything about that?
It's fantastic, and they
get five weeks on it.
That's good.
Celebrate that.
But they made choices to
take out what's contemporary
because clearly the they,
whoever was making all these
choices in the College Board
saw this as where the
controversy would be.
And I don't know exactly when.
Somebody will ferret this out.
There's a journalist out who's
gonna figure all this out.
Maybe even a historian
about who did this and when,
you know, in 2022, and
when did they really decide
to take critical race theory out.
I don't know.
It was in originally and then it's not.
So also last point, last point.
Look, what I wanna know is
how many teachers were asked,
and there were teachers involved
in this process, I'm told.
But how many, I don't know.
Maybe Mira, you know,
how many actual high school teachers
are involved in the
creation of these courses?
How many teachers weighed
in on what they teach
or what they want to teach or
what they know how to teach?
That would be very valuable to know.
Cause they're the people
who have to do it,
and they do have
discretion in how to teach.
They don't all teach exactly
the same thing on the same day.
Teachers have discretion
in these programs.
And we shouldn't talk about
this AP African-American Studies course
as if it's a curriculum from on high
that everybody must do the same.
But it is true, they made a choice
to make about eight or nine
of these units at the end
optional for research papers.
Now it could just happen
that young people are so
interested in this stuff,
they're all gonna write
their papers on it.
Who knows.
- Thanks, David.
I mean that, and that
does raise questions then
about teachers that would choose
to foreground those issues
more intentionally.
- They might, many might.
- The vulnerability, right?
There's a kind of like,
you've been warned.
- Some states especially, yes.
- And particularly for teachers
of color and Black teachers
who are much more likely to
be viewed with suspicion.
You know, don't you know we
laid out the directions here,
and the possibility that
one may have discretion
over some parts, right?
What text to use in introducing, right,
kind of early abolitionist thought.
You know, there, but here.
- Especially in the two dozen states
that have divisive concept laws,
- Right, working with it there, yeah.
- Teaching under a divisive concept law.
- Right, yeah, and how that changes
the working conditions of teachers.
- Yeah, right.
- At a moment of profound
need in public education.
Jason, let's turn to you.
I mean, part of this is also, you know,
history is about kind of facts.
Yeah, it's just events.
And what we don't wanna do
is impose something, right?
There is a kind of theory-less
history, so, well, yeah,
what's your kind of take on that
and how that allows us to understand
or not organize our sense of the past?
- Yeah, so no philosopher of history
would ever say history is
just a series of facts.
History is a narrative
structured by a narrative.
That's basic to the philosophy of history.
So the quest is, so really it's
all philosophy when you get.
(cross talking and chuckling)
So you have to ask what narrative
are they trying to eliminate?
What narrative are they targeting?
And the narrative they're targeting
is the narrative that
drew me as a philosopher
into the study of recent US history.
For me as a philosopher,
and this is the main topic of my 2015 book
"How Propaganda Works,"
I wanted to know how after
the civil rights movement,
after this movement for liberation,
racial injustice completely persisted.
Mass incarceration,
what we now incarcerate,
200,000 people are serving life sentences
that's basically roughly
the full prison system
when I was born.
So how after the civil rights movement
in a country that lauds
the civil rights movement,
do we end up with resegregation?
In 2014, 2015, last
time I spun the numbers,
almost 10% of the
world's prison population
came from the formerly enslaved population
of the United States.
So the theorists they're targeting
are the ones that theorize about that.
The theorists they're targeting
are the ones that say, wait,
the civil rights movement
didn't solve all the problems.
And so that's what they're trying to do.
They're trying to say, we
solved racial injustice.
Martin Luther King, that's
why we've got a holiday.
And that's very clearly
what they're trying to do.
They're trying to eliminate any studies
of the practices and
structures of the institutions,
of the police, of the
criminal legal system,
of the school system that results,
of banking that keeps
the racial wealth gap
basically what it was before
the Civil rights movement.
Yale's, my colleague Jennifer Richardson,
from whose work I've learned so much,
studies the myth of the
myth of racial progress,
the myth of the narrative
of racial progress.
White Americans think that Black Americans
have 90% of the wealth of white Americans
when they have 10% of the wealth.
So what they're trying to do
is they're trying to make inexplicable
Black movements for social justice.
They're trying to make it so
that when you see a protest,
you're like what are
they complaining about?
We have Martin Luther King Day.
So it's very clear to me
what they're trying to do.
They're trying to remove all structural,
any kind of study of structures
and practices that persist
and make us think
that because we have Martin
Luther King Day, we did it.
So, and finally, I wanna note,
I wanna end on this question
of no political content,
which as David said, you know,
the most political content of all
is saying that you have
no political content.
So as you all know from your
arguments in your dorms,
but suppose that somebody said,
we're going to make illegal
the concept of sexual harassment.
Suppose someone said, and suppose
like 18 states passed laws
making it illegal to teach the
concept of sexual harassment.
You couldn't mention it,
you couldn't talk about it.
Nobody would be fooled about
what's going on, right?
So why has there not been an outcry
about the concept of intersectionality?
Sexual harassment affects black women,
white women, all women.
Intersectionality is only
about a subset of women.
Is it because it's about that subset
that there there isn't the
outrage that there should be?
- Great, thanks Jason.
And I think there's, you know,
just a couple things there.
One is saying there's a clear relationship
between the content of a history course
and how you understand what's
natural or not in the world.
It orients your expectations,
your desires, your hopes.
It very much allows you to
discern or not discern things.
That's partly what's at stake.
And the taking away of a
particular kind of framework
actually denies, right, a
whole subset of students,
you know, Baldwin in his, you
know, Talk to Teachers Essay,
says this.
Students see everything.
They see the inequalities.
They see the humiliation.
They, you know, they
see the possibilities.
They come to classroom
asking what's happening here?
And the notion that a
teacher would be told,
we can't talk about that.
Or what you're seeing is
just as your other example,
it's just random.
If you see someone you know, humiliated,
it's likely their fault.
Yeah, so you're, you
know, and that produces
a certain kind of understanding,
and that's not power neutral in that way.
So that's really helpful.
Rod, let's turn to you now.
I'm also very much
thinking about your work
on student movements
and reminding us about
the capacious imagination
they had for these classes
and how you might put that into dialogue
with what we're seeing now.
- Yeah, I mean, you know,
if we think about the
student protest movements,
but also just the general
social protest movements
at the end of the 60s,
the beginning of the 70s,
you know, what we saw actually,
and contrary to the popular narrative
is that the Black Panthers
were in conversation
with the gay liberation folks.
Marcia B. Johnson, Sylvia Rivera,
the members of Street Transvestite
Action Revolutionaries
in conversation with Huey P. Newton.
Newton writing the communique
about women's and gay liberation, right.
The didactics house in Philadelphia,
learning from and producing
their own kind of socialist,
lesbian, anti-racist, feminism,
the Combahee River Collective.
So all of these groups were in
conversation with each other,
being inspired by each other,
trying to learn from one another
and also then producing a kind
of cartography of struggle.
Right, and here we are now with an edict
to abolish those cartographies, right?
This is what that's about, right?
It's the reason that
we're targeted, you know,
that our colleagues,
Angela Davis, you know,
Robin, Kelly targeted.
It's because, you know,
people have been working
to produce cartographies
so that we can make links.
That's what intersectionality is.
You know, how do I think about the links
between modes of difference
and histories that are
supposed to be disconnected
from one another?
That's the threat, right?
That's the word.
That people are actually
producing frameworks
by which they can see the
links between things, right?
That they're not discreet
entities, that there are overlaps.
That there are affinities.
And if we do that, then there
might be the possibility
that there could be strange
affinities, unlikely alliances,
you know, between those groups.
You know?
That's what strikes terror
in the hearts of these folks, okay.
- Yeah, I just, Rod, that's
just so important and moving
because I think it also pushes us past,
so we can say there's an edict,
I think is a helpful term here, right?
Because their disavowing edict,
but the elimination of a queer
presence in the curriculum,
a feminist intersectional,
one could read as well,
that's a kind of, it's simply
bias, and they're just,
they need to be more open to it.
But you're saying it's not just that.
It's not just, you know,
because one could even imagine
incorporation of a presence
that's not doing that work there.
So there's something much more at stake
in the kind of purging of
those bodies of knowledge.
It never happened, and it's not
something you have available
to think with.
Okay, Kim, let's turn to you now
to think also about this
question of history.
Actually, I just wanna
intersperse a comment from Daisha.
So Daisha Brabham, who was
supposed to be on the panel,
is a Windsor high school teacher.
She teaches a Black and
latino studies course
in Connecticut.
And she wrote in preparation
after she realized she
wasn't able to come.
"One immediate effect in the
classroom of these policies
"is to further distort students' reality
"of the past and present.
"One of the rationales put
forward by the College Board
"is that by taking away the
more theoretical aspects
"of the curriculum.
"But that same rationale
is not being applied
"to the ideas of James Madison
and Alexander Hamilton,
"who are also producing
theories on government.
"The product of this is to imply further
"that Black people are not contributors
"or capable of theory or thought.
"One of my students recently wrote a paper
"comparing Crenshaw's
ideas on intersectionality
"to another 20th century thinker.
"These exercises are essential
"if you're going to teach
about James Madison's ideas
"on democracy, then it's equally essential
"to consider Angela Davis's
ideas on abolition democracy."
So I, you know, and you
talked about this today,
in your, about public health,
about the kind of re-energizing of ideas
about racial superiority and inferiority
that come about in these
disavowed settings.
But let's turn to you
now to kind of help us
think about these histories.
- Yeah, well, and let me add,
the assumption is also
that students can't learn
about democracy.
They can't learn about the government.
They can't learn about the
state from the experiences
that prompted them
to want to have this
course in the first place.
So some of the irony, I guess
we might call it in the story,
is that the very conditions of possibility
that opened up this course,
the aftermath of George Floyd
and Breonna Taylor,
the contemporary dimensions
of the histories,
that's precisely the information
that's precisely the thinking
that has now been rendered optional.
And I just wanna say, as far
as teachers are concerned,
what this also does is to tell teachers
you can teach this at your own peril.
It deprives them of the ability to say,
no, this is part of the AP curriculum.
So it's effectively saying to teachers
who have now been subjected to
in many of these states
that have memory laws,
surveillance in the classroom, fines,
the possibility of being
sued, losing their jobs,
and then beyond that losing their license.
It's not just losing their
jobs but losing their license.
So what this has done is deprive them
of some institutional capacity to say,
what I am doing is authorized.
What I am doing is legitimate.
What I am doing is important
to the educational project.
So I wanna say that
part of the conversation
about when did it happen,
whether the teachers were consulted,
there is an interesting problem
in whether they've been consulted
because right now the course
has not been fully taught,
the information that has to,
they're halfway through.
So what are you gonna
consult the teachers about,
about the stuff that's taken out
because they haven't even had
an opportunity to teach it.
In law that's called, you know,
sort of contradictory evidence, right?
But what I wanna suggest
is even our focus on
did they do it a couple of weeks ago
or have they done it for a whole year
is a problematic framework
cause it makes it seem as
though the damage that's done
is only damage if someone
intended it to be done.
It's only damage if it's intended to be
in response to DeSantis's
claims last week.
But in critical race theory,
one of the things we do is
suggest that damage is done,
whether it's intended or not.
Damage is done whether it
happened last week or last year.
Damage is done, right?
Because effectively what this has created
is a course that basically
gives the students
letters from ancient history,
but doesn't give them the
grammar to put it together
into meaning in the here and now.
So what does it mean to say, yeah,
we had a lot of history in it,
but we decided not to say anything
or not to make the
movement for Black Lives
a legitimate topic that
is required in the course.
What does it mean to say,
okay, we might have talked a
little bit about World War II
and maybe we talked about
the Federal Housing Act
depriving Black GIS of
the same kind of access
to housing in suburbs.
Maybe it meant that they
didn't get the same opportunity
as white people did.
But what we're not talking
about is that deprivation
of that opportunity in the 40s, in the 50s
has now ballooned into
billions of dollars of wealth
that white GIS were able to
get and pass on to their kids,
pass on that Black GIS weren't.
Our students in this course
won't be able to really talk about that
because that has to do with
contemporary inequalities.
And the whole point of
this attack is to say,
we can talk about history
as much as we want,
but where we're drawing the line
is in saying that that has anything to do
with the here and now.
Because if it has something
to do with the here and now,
it implicates what people need to be doing
in the here and now to really make good
on the promises of equity and inclusion.
And that's precisely
what divisive concepts
are basically against.
So I just wanna say
that part of this debate
that they're having is kind
of affirming the very ideas
that they don't want in it
in the first place, right?
They're affirming the
idea that it only counts
if we did it because DeSantis told us to.
Not it counts because we are
depriving a new generation
of the education they need
to understand the lives
that they've been born into.
(audience applauding)
- I think,
and I just want to bring
in Daisha one more time,
and then we'll go to the third part
because it speaks, you
know, directly to that,
the question of what historical knowledge
can be mobilized to do
outside of just events.
And so Daisha comments,
"Carol Anderson, a really
important historian's book
"'White Rage' is essential for us to see
"that these attacks are not
new, but should be expected.
"Behind every civil rights
gain lies an attack.
"The fact that many are
unaware of the struggle
"behind the aftermath of Brown V Board
"or the removal of troops
"after the reconstruction amendments
"demonstrate yet another
indictment on the education system
"that we are consistently
not telling the whole story.
"Treating these wins as the products
"of individual characters
or inevitable success
"when the truth is that it was the product
"of decades worth of
organizing in communities."
So I think it's a just
another astute way of saying
you can actually take the
same kind of like line
on the timeline event,
and the framework with
which it's discussed
and engaged with students makes
all the difference, right?
All the difference.
We're not gonna go to our last round,
and we'll continue to invite
you to put your questions there
as we put those together.
Yeah, we have those here,
and here we're trying
to really think about
where do we go from here.
So I'd like each of you
to think about your sense
of two roads that might
lead from this moment.
The first in which this
decision is simply endorsed,
accepted, maybe some hand wringing,
but otherwise with little objection,
either because it's pragmatic to do.
Simply we have to accept the conditions
or it's just not worth the fight.
It's actually not, it's not
relevant to other concerns.
What happens, and what
danger does it promise
beyond Florida high schools?
The second in which we
see this as a moment
that requires concerted
and collective action.
What might that action look like?
And what kinds of futures
could we potentially build?
And for this, Rod, we're
gonna turn to you first,
if that's all right.
- One object to it, right?
Simply object to it.
As you're objecting to it,
go back to Martin Luther King's letter
from the Birmingham Jail, okay?
In that letter, he defines,
theorizes direct action.
All right, and says why
direct action is needed.
When a society refuses to come to grips
with its historical moment,
a creative tension has to be produced.
The creative tension can be produced
through collective mobilization, right?
The use of the body, the
use of culture forms,
culture practices.
Read that and then do
something with it, okay?
Ironically, the other thing that we can do
that the DeSantis folks say they want,
that will actually go a long way,
read and write, okay?
So the stuff that they don't
want you to read, read it.
Okay, the things that they
are saying should not be read.
Imagine that as a list of
recommendations, you know?
As a syllabus in and of itself.
You know, pass those onto
other people, all right?
Produce the classroom outside
of the classroom, right?
In your dorms, in your
clubs, with your families.
All right, let's take back that
moment when it was illegal,
for instance, for black people,
black enslaved people
to read and to write.
So what did they do?
They had things like
midnight schools, all right,
where they produced critical
education, you know,
away from, you know, the
master's purview, right?
Produce those, multiply them.
And also demand that that curriculum
belongs also in public education,
you know, in K through 12.
And that it also, it belongs
in university settings
because that's what's coming next.
You know, don't be lulled into thinking
that this will just stay
with K through 12 teachers.
Okay, you know, the other
target will be higher education.
We already see that with DeSantis saying
that he is going to go after
diversity, equity, and
inclusion units, you know,
within colleges and
universities, all right?
So that's what's at stake.
Multiply the instances and moments
and context for critical education.
Get involved, produce your
own direct action, all right?
It only takes a handful
of folks, you know.
What did Audre Lorde say?
Find your work and do it, period.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks, Rod.
Before we go to Jason, I
just wanna underscore right,
of course the notion that there
might be some robust version
of African American studies,
ethnic studies at Yale
at another place, even as
the rest of the, you know,
that is no ethnic studies,
that is no, right?
It's completely antithetical.
And even for in higher ed, you know,
graduate students pursuing
teaching and research jobs,
you know, teachers wanting
to go into the field,
all of this will affect you.
People who are working
on abolition, right?
All of these topics have
now been subject to censure.
I never thought in 15 years
I would work with a graduate
student in these fields
and advise them
before they give their
ethnic studies job talk,
they might have to tone down the politics
and the transformation.
The whole purpose was
that this was the field
that these things could be,
where the knowledge
could be produced, right?
So the fact that they're now saying
that the discipline is coming here.
No one is exempt from that.
Jason, let's turn to you now
in that sense, two roads,
what happens if we don't act
and what are the possibilities if we do?
- Yeah, I hate to be Debbie Downer,
but that's kind of my work.
What happens if we don't take
the kind of route Rod suggested?
I think, I think Danny,
you phrased it a little
too optimistically.
Like you were like, oh, well, you know,
if it's just ethnic
studies being free at Yale,
but it's not free elsewhere
in public universities,
then you know, it still
will affect us indirectly.
No, it'll come for Yale too.
It'll, like that's one thing
if you look internationally,
you might think, oh, they'll just stop
at the public universities.
And it's already well beyond K through 12.
Texas Lieutenant Governor
said he's gonna fire
all the University of
Texas at Austin faculty
who teach critical race theory, who teach,
I taught, Tim Snyder and I
taught Angela Davis on Tuesday
in our class.
So that would be illegal.
We'd be fire-able for the
University of Texas and Austin,
which is supposed to
be a great university.
So it's already coming for public schools,
public universities, and we
can, and you might think, okay,
but we're at private
universities, we're safe.
Na-uh, Orbán, Viktor
Orbán already figured out
how to deal with that problem.
He got Central European University
using various legalities
to close up shop, the best
university in Hungary,
a private university.
He got them to close up
shop and move to Vienna.
So, and they're imitating dissent.
They're dissenters.
They're imitating Orbán
because Orbán was the speaker
at the keynote at the National
Conservatives Conference.
And he was very skilled
at taking over the courts
and targeting private concerns.
He forced the whole free press
to sell itself to his friends
by suddenly everybody
faced enormous tax bills.
And if you listen to JD Vance,
whose talk at the National
Conservatives Conference was
"Our Enemy is the Professors,"
I believe it was called.
The idea was that they'll get,
they're theorizing very explicitly
how to go after the private universities.
They'll go after our endowments.
They'll go after, well,
I'm in favor of that, but.
(audience laughing)
They'll go after, yeah, they'll
go after federal funding.
They'll go after,
there's a number of ways
they can play with tax codes.
There's a number of ways
they they can imitate
what's happened in Eastern Europe here
with privates as well.
So it's gonna, they're
gonna come after everybody.
And this is a corporation too.
And so, just like the College Board,
they care about profits here
too, so don't be fooled.
So the goal is, as
Professor Crenshaw said,
that you look at present
events and be baffled.
So that's their end goal,
and what they're doing,
if you look at what we let
happen in the United States,
there's a book called
"Laboratories of Autocracy"
about states like
Wisconsin, North Carolina,
where basically the
United States was like,
okay, let's have a little
Hungary inside the United States
where the state, if the
democratic governor wins,
the state legislature,
gerrymandered in state legislature
will vote to strip the
governor of his powers.
Every time they have a
democratic governor in Wisconsin
and North Carolina, that's what they do.
And at first everyone was outraged,
and everyone's like, okay,
that's just Wisconsin
and North Carolina.
We can't let this happen
because once you let it happen,
you know, everyone's like,
well, it's just like that state.
It's just another state.
So we've done it already
with state houses.
We've done it with gerrymandering.
We've done it with our congressional,
our congress people.
North Carolina gerrymandered maps.
They're trying to, you know,
50/50 vote Democrat and
Republican, but you know, you know,
75% of their representative
Congress people are Republicans.
So we can't let it happen with education.
- Great, thank you, Jason.
(audience applauding)
Again, remind you to look at the,
to message text your question in
so that we have about
15 minutes remaining.
So before we get to David
and Kim to close us out,
just gonna bring Daisha in one
more time on this last point.
Who says, "Although the
recent attacks of CRT
"are making mainstream,
there are more silent attacks
"happening every day in the
underfunding of schools,
"the removal of elective
courses for students
"that often expose them to classes
"such as AP African-American
history being removed
"because of a lack of staff, et cetera.
"The attack on education is far reaching,
"and we cannot lose in this debate."
And then "We must now remain vigilant
"and use the community
framework to work together,
"collective action,
community activist projects
"to address the educational
malpractice we see in Florida
"and across the country.
"In the words of James Brown,
"we need to get up, get
into it, and get involved.
"Parents, students,
teachers, administrators
"and families in the community together
"to mediate and strategize the
short and long-term effects
"of this attack.
"We need an all hands on deck strategy."
And I just wanna say,
it's again to the point of like teachers
who are experiencing this most acutely
and profoundly understand
the landscape and see it
as a matter of academic freedom for sure,
but also deeply tied to
many other transformations
that they and their students experience.
David, we're gonna turn to
you and then finish with Kim.
Two roads, which way?
- Well, your first road is not an option.
I think we're all saying that.
And Daisha, if you're watching,
thanks for setting me up
cause I wanna talk about public schools.
A lot of us met Daisha last
fall at our conference here
that the Gilder Lehrman Center did
about teaching slavery and race.
And we celebrated
teachers to say the least.
I'll come back to the public schools.
You know, and I wanna endorse,
well, I wanna endorse
the David Pepper book
that you mentioned about
state legislatures.
That's an extremely
important book to read.
If you wanna understand
what's really happened
to American politics.
The action is in the states, folks.
It's not as sexy.
Run for state legislature,
isn't that exciting?
You want an interview
with a state legislature?
No, you don't.
You want an interview with an iBank?
Sorry. (audience laughing)
Anyway, but we need you
in the state legislature
and all right, all right, enough of that.
But that book by David
Pepper is brilliant.
First of all, I went back,
I'll do this real quickly.
One thing we need to know here
is that African American
studies is a deep old tradition.
It's 55 to 60 years old as
a curriculum phenomenon.
This is a little bit memory
lane, and it makes me old,
which I am, but I first taught
an AFAM intro course in 1988
at Harvard, where I spent two years.
We were just inventing a new version.
And that summer of 1988,
I was privileged to be part of an NEH
like three week workshop
on how to create introductory courses
in African-American studies.
It was, and I just dug out a
whole bunch of my old files.
It was fun.
We had experts, most of them now dead.
We had James Gibbs, the anthropologist.
We had Al Raboteau, the great
historian of Black religion.
We had all kinds of people come.
We had one gentleman, Julius Wilson, come
and spend a whole day talking
about urban sociology,
on and, we had Hazel Carby come
and talk about literature and women.
It was phenomenal.
And what we learned is
this whole field began
really in anthropology.
It began in the great
debates over Herskovitz,
and E. Franklin Frazier.
And what's African about
African-American culture
which is a never ending debate.
It's fascinating stuff.
We ended with a whole long
unit on Black literature,
and in the middle, an incredible unit.
Unit, we spent days on this,
on the historiography of slavery,
which circa late 80s was still
booming in a certain way.
It's still booming.
And we created courses.
You'd be amazed at the
readings on these courses.
The tradition is so deep,
and sometimes you just
need to tell people that.
This isn't brand new
just because the AP is
creating a course on it
for god's sake.
And then I moved to Amherst College
where we had Black Studies 11,
which was our Introduction
to Black Studies.
We team taught it.
It was one of the most fun experiences
I've ever had teaching with
like three colleagues at once.
We had to have a historian, a philosopher,
and a literary critic
all weighing in on this.
And my goodness, it was rich.
Sometimes we'd have students
in the class who, you know,
they'd have to read this and read that,
and it was intensive reading.
And they'd say, can we just talk about
what it's like to be Black at Amherst?
No, we'd say, do the reading.
We can talk about that later if you want.
But you know, you all know that situation.
Here's the syllabus, but here's my life.
And we found that we had to put
a little more time in on that sometimes.
Anyway, I'll spare you any
more of this memory lane.
But this is a deep old tradition,
and it's gone through all kinds
of permutations and changes.
Last point.
Good, I got a minute.
Roderick is absolutely right.
Organize politically.
This is a political question of power.
We need a social movement
in the United States,
tantamount to Black Lives
Matter and even bigger.
It needs Soros level of funding and more
to save, preserve, enhance
the public schools.
85% of Americans are
educated in a public school.
I went to nothing but public schools.
I taught seven years in
a public high school.
I have no education
without public schools.
The public school is the
most democratic thing
the United States ever invented.
(audience applauding)
And there is a multi-billion
dollar crusade to destroy them.
(someone quietly talking)
- Yeah, I mean look.
- [Woman] Say that louder!
- By enslaved black people,
that's where the public
education system comes from.
- Well, it does in great parts.
They were.
- Just go ahead and read.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, no,
it does, it does, it does.
Although they were trying
to create these things
in Massachusetts earlier too,
and they did.
One state mandated public
schools before the Civil War,
so you're right.
But hey, you want a new social movement?
Save the public schools and go teach.
(audience applauding)
- All right, Kim, we're
gonna get some, you know,
questions here, but yeah,
we're at this moment.
We've heard what's at stake,
and we've heard generally
and broadly, you know,
where we need to go.
But I'm hoping you can also help us
kind of deepen that a little bit
and talk about both and certainly
related to the APF work,
what are the campaigns,
what are the possibilities,
the alliances that help to build that?
- Yeah, so I wanna start
where David left off
and raise a question.
This campaign that we've been part,
that we've been witnessing
over the last couple of years,
it hasn't been mysterious
about what its objectives were.
They've said straight up,
they're hoping to sow
dissatisfaction with public education
in order to dismantle it.
And they're starting with
the frameworks that they know
people are most ambivalent about
and the people that people feel
less concerned with, right?
So, where has everybody
been for the last two years
with this divisive concepts idea?
Where has everybody been with the attack
on critical race theory?
Where has everybody been in this notion
that education is meant
to make people feel good?
This is like MAGA education.
To make America great
again, you've gotta believe
that it used to be great for everybody.
And the only way you can sustain that
is to erase the parts of the
history that were not great.
Where has everybody been
while this is going on?
It's not about what happened last week.
It is about what has been generated
for the last two years at minimum.
So what it makes me question
is whether we are moving
to another moment,
which I call race McCarthyism,
where there's a set of ideas
that people say are toxic,
radioactive, anyone that has
anything to do with them,
anyone who cites anyone that
has anything to do with them,
anyone who reads those ideas,
they are dangerous people.
And the rest of us will sometimes
just disavow those ideas
and those people.
So think about what the
conversation has been
for the last two years.
When it's come up, is critical
race theory being taught?
Most people are like, oh, no, no, no.
We're not teaching critical race theory.
Now you actually look at
what they're actually saying
and doing.
They're, exactly.
It's a matter of what it's called, right?
But here's the thing.
You cannot outrun what it is
because what they're after is not the name
but the set of ideas.
So if you're teaching those ideas,
if you're talking about structural racism,
you're not gonna be saved by saying,
but it's not critical race theory.
You're saying that current
inequality is in part the product
of the past that is neutrally
institutionalized everywhere.
You're not gonna be saved by it.
Once they get done with people
who are clearly critical race theorists,
our history tells us they
come after the next group.
All history tells us they
come after the next group,
American history, European history,
you can broaden it to
other histories as well.
So we know this,
but we're not acting
as though we know this.
And I wanna ask the question why.
Is it because it's about
difficult conversations
that everybody has a hard time with?
So there's a little bit
of, yeah, you know what?
That kind of race stuff
can get kind of hard.
Maybe we shouldn't be talking about it.
Maybe there really is a there there
that I don't have to worry about
because it's just about that.
Whatever people thought
up until last week,
they should not be thinking it anymore.
Because it's abundantly
clear that this isn't about
whether you call it critical
race theory, intersectionality.
It's about education that
allows people to understand
the historical groundwork
upon which this contemporary society
and all of its inequalities are based.
And if we cannot name that,
if we cannot talk about it,
if we cannot frame it,
whether it's through theory or narrative,
we are unable to change it.
And that is exactly the point.
So now that we know that,
now that it's clear what
they're going after,
and let's be clear, DeSantis also said
he's going after diversity,
equity, and inclusion
on campuses.
He's going after courses.
He's going after professors
who he doesn't want to testify,
use their knowledge to
testify in law cases
around civil rights.
So this is a total takeover
of the knowledge producing industry.
So what are we going
to do about it, right?
Now I will say that one of the things
that has been surprising to me
is how little colleges,
presidents, administrators,
have thought that they needed
to say anything about this.
Like, where are the presidents?
Where are the people to say
it's time to do something
and defend our institution
and the project that we have been about.
Now, what I know, what
I've heard, what I've seen
is that there's a
reluctance to get involved,
a reluctance to be seen as political,
but it's kind of like, you know,
when someone's coming
to burn down your house,
for you to say I'm not
gonna throw some water on it
because that would be
political, that's just suicide.
When people are coming after
the very mission of your institution,
for you not to defend it
is to basically give them
the keys to the house.
And that's effectively
what I think is happening.
So where does this go
if we don't intervene?
I think we know where it goes.
You know, history tells us where it goes.
The only thing is we probably
believe that we are immune
because we are the
United States of America.
And that stuff doesn't happen here.
My only response to
that is that just shows
you don't know our history
cause that stuff has happened here.
It was called redemption.
This is real.
So part of what the African
American Policy Forum has done
is we've tried to take
a a page out of history.
We've tried to create something
that we call the Freedom Writers
and Freedom Readers book tour.
Our analogy was that Freedom Writers,
these are the folks in the 60s
who put their bodies on the line
to fight against segregation.
And their understanding of
what they were doing was,
you know, power doesn't get
to tell us where to sit,
where to eat, where to
study, where to pray.
Just like power didn't tell
Freedom Writers where to go,
where to be, how to vote.
Today they don't get to tell
us what to read, what to write,
what to learn, what to teach.
And if we allow them
to tell us what to read
and what to teach, they're
telling us who we can be.
And that cannot be what
all of this movement
for the last 60 years has been about.
We cannot come to this point
where we're willing to pass on
a legacy that is half full or
a baton that cannot be reached
by the next generation.
So we created a book tour.
We took 19 of the titles
that have been banned
in states around the country,
and we gave them away.
We said, if they don't
want you to read it,
you should take it as a reading list.
And better yet, we're
gonna be your Amazon.
We gonna bring it to you.
Which is exactly what we've been doing.
And we have found that when we are talking
directly to people,
we're not trying to mediate
through the media saying,
well, actually, you know,
critical race theory
is the legal infrastructure
behind structural racism.
When we're not trying to talk to them,
but we're actually talking
to people and saying
the reason why your neighborhood
is under sourced and underfunded
is because of your zip code.
It's because of the zoning.
It's because of the tax base.
It's because of the Federal Housing Act.
We are making it clear and plain
that what people wake up to every day
is not based on what they've
done or their choices.
It's based on what our
society has put into play
and how it's structured for the future.
When you tell people that
directly, they understand it,
they support it, and they get mad
that people are trying to
take it away from them.
So what we're all about is
like I am all about go teach.
I am about taking this
information to families.
I am about political activation,
but not just in the small d
way, not even the big D way,
but in the way that says,
if we do not fight for
our democracy right now,
we will not have it to
fight for in the future.
And that is what I think is at stake.
It might look like it's just
about a little thing right now.
It might look like it's just about AP.
It might look like it's
about intersectionality,
critical race theory,
queer theory, but trust,
if they are successful in the red states
and in some sections of the blue states
in making this the law,
it will be the future
that we will inherit.
And I frankly don't think
that that's what we want.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Kim.
So we have a couple of
minutes left, and I just want,
so my understanding is the reception
will have some of those books.
We'll have materials about the campaigns,
how people can get involved in them,
a chance to talk to the staff
about those possibilities.
A couple of questions here, and this,
and I'm just gonna go one more.
The first word from Daisha was
"The College Board is not our friend."
"And, you know, the defense of them,
"or the surprise that their
speedy flip-flop demonstrates
"a more significant issue at hand
"as to what these attacks
were meant to cause."
She actually says, and I
think this is really helpful,
"They were meant to cause
us to be reactionary,"
by which I think it also
means right to think about
who among us we should be suspicious of,
despise, et cetera, right?
Whatever in anti solidarity.
There's a couple of questions
that are actually focused on
the very project of AP classes,
which before this we know are
a part of a system of sorting,
deeply inequitable in terms
of who has access to them,
reproducing racial hierarchies.
So how, I wanna just invite
you to all say a little bit,
maybe just to start with
Rod, on the one hand,
we don't wanna say this is insignificant
because it's simply a, you know,
kind of elite box of courses.
But on the other hand, as you said,
the only way to learn this
is not simply through an AP class.
So how do you think about that and yeah,
the kind of the relationship
in the class on these broader,
the broader histories and
genealogies of Black studies?
- Yeah, I mean, I think that, you know,
we are at a moment
where this is not just
about the AP course, right?
This is about the integrity of education,
you know, at this
historical juncture, right?
I mean, I will say that, you know,
I didn't answer the emails from
the College Board last year
and all the times that they
were sending me those emails
because it's the College Board.
I want the SAT to go away.
You know? (audience applauding)
I do not think that it is in keeping
with the history of Black
progressive thought,
which let's face it,
that's the dominant of Black history.
I mean, Black intellectual
history is Black progressives.
You know, I mean,
you can talk about like the
conservatives and whatever,
but what are you gonna do
with the rest of those weeks?
(audience laughing) You know?
And so, you know, so I do not think
that what we need to have is a more elite
and now watered down
experience with Black studies.
That is not in keeping with Black studies.
CLR James said that Black studies
is the critique of Western civilization.
Okay, he didn't say it
was the purview of those
with high GPAs.
You know, he didn't say that.
All right, so this is a
radically democratic project,
and we need to preserve that
and insist upon that, okay?
- Great, thank you, thank you.
Maybe just a question for David,
which is also about the
possibilities and imperatives
to also transform the
way US history is taught
and as an ongoing site of yeah struggle.
- Well, first of all, US
history has transformed
in enormous ways in the last decades.
It simply has.
Let's not kid ourselves.
Now, does that always trickle
down to the high schools?
Of course not.
I've been teaching summer
institutes for secondary teachers
for, I don't know, 27 years or something.
I've taught thousands of,
they're usually well
motivated high school teachers
in the summer.
They're hungry, they're eager.
Often because they don't know much.
They want to take a seminar on slavery
because they didn't learn much about it.
But that doesn't mean
they're not ready to learn
and ready to be taught by
some of the best historians.
So let's not kid ourselves.
In fact, I wrote this piece
called "Trust the Teachers,"
I guess in the Atlantic or someplace,
and I said, look, you wanna blame somebody
for all that's going on
about Black history and race
all over curriculums.
Blame us.
Blame the historians.
Bring it on.
We'll take the fight.
Don't blame the teachers.
Trust the teachers to learn something.
Last point, we all gotta start somewhere.
Next fall, in late September,
Gilda Lehrman Center and
maybe others here at Yale,
are helping co-sponsor a conference
at Flagler College in
St. Augustine in Florida
in what, the leader there
of this effort calls
behind the red curtain.
Now that's a private college,
although they are not
untied to state monies
because most of their buildings
are like state landmarks.
So they got some risk to take,
and their president is on board, I think.
But we're working with
some cool faculty there
who wanna do like a two and a half day
knockdown drag out conference
about how is history taught?
How is Black history taught?
How should it be taught?
We're gonna bring in Kim.
Kim doesn't know she's coming yet.
We're gonna bring in Kim Crenshaw
and a whole bunch of other people.
We'll have keynotes, but teachers,
Florida teachers with the guts to show up.
And that's a question.
We had some Florida teachers
here at our conference
last fall who were frankly afraid to come.
They can't even, they're
afraid to use their emails.
Even in state universities.
I have three former PhD students
who teach in state
universities in Florida.
I emailed them and said,
what are you all doing?
Aren't you gonna surround
the capitol and raise hell?
And they said, I'll
answer you on my Gmail.
So this is kind of the
way they live every day.
But let's not kid ourselves.
But what happens in the academy,
the history, we change all the
time and rewrite and rewrite
and argue like hell with each other.
And sometimes it gets into good textbooks.
Usually it gets in good textbooks.
Usually it gets out sometimes
in synthetic works of narrative, we hope.
And it gets out in biographies.
But the task is to convert
these explosions of knowledge
we have had in the academy
for two, three generations
to the public schools, to
the public who wants to read.
That's still our task.
I don't have any perfect
formulas for doing that,
but at least when you get tenure,
get the hell out of your own
campus and talk to real people.
Cause they actually do
wanna learn something.
(audience applauding)
And even before you get tenure.
- Thank you, David.
- But come down to St.
Augustine in late September.
We're gonna raise hell
behind the red curtain.
- We have, we're gonna do
two more quick questions.
I have a short question for Jason,
and then we're gonna turn
it to Kim to leave off.
I should also say, obviously
where we are in New Haven,
there's a public school
system with dynamic teachers,
incredible students.
That's been consistently,
consistently denied
the resources it needs.
- And a teacher shortage.
- Yes, and a very powerful
and growing movement
among teachers, parents, and
students to insist, you know,
the same things that are being said there
that exist in our own state,
which has among the
deepest racial inequalities
and economic disparities.
So I hope everyone is also
on the lookout for that work
cause there's concrete opportunities.
And we know in this institution at Yale
have consciousness that
many of those disparities
are linked to the resources we have
because of the taxes that
we don't pay into it.
So there's a version of that, right,
that we have to account for here as well.
I wanna just, a quick question to Jason
and then some final words from Kim.
History is one side of
these contestations,
but there's many other disciplines.
Sometimes people think,
let's say a discipline like classics.
Well by its nature, right,
all the classics folks,
you're excused.
This doesn't involve you, right?
But in fact, that's the very site
where certain authoritative forms
of racialized knowledge are constituted.
So can you just say a
little bit more about those
and then we'll turn to
Kim for (audio blurs)
- Seeing that DeSantis
is going hard on this.
He's saying, we're gonna
do classical education.
We're gonna have (audio cuts out)
We're gonna make sure
everyone reads just classics.
And now this is something I learned
from my friend Charles Mills who said,
you know who's channeling Plato now?
It's the Black intellectual tradition.
Who's doing philosophy of education?
In my philosophy of education class,
I begin with Plato and
I end with Bell Hooks
because in the 20th century,
who is talking about education
in a political system?
It is the people denied that education.
Those are where the
conversations are happening.
So if you're going to
teach classical education
in the 20th century,
that's really gonna end,
those questions, those set of questions.
When Plato in the Republic
says, when he's asked,
what's the first question
of justice in the city?
What's the first issue?
He says how you educate people.
And who in the United States
writes about education?
Who are the great education theorists?
Well, it starts with an argument.
I mean, it goes, you know,
Anna Julia Cooper, Dubois,
all the way to Bell Hooks and beyond.
That's a conversation.
Those classical questions,
those are the Black
intellectual traditions.
So don't let them take the
classical tradition from you.
- Great, thank you, yeah.
All right.
This has been amazing, Kim, right?
It's really, really, and
obviously more to come.
There is a question here,
but I don't, that points out
DeSantis is a Yale graduate.
I think David Coleman.
- [David] It's our responsibility.
- Yeah. (Panelists quietly talking)
- Is that a defense?
- [David] No!
- It's more of a, like,
what's going on here?
- But I think there's a
way that the question,
you know, a cynicism
can take over us, right?
We think like we're simply,
like nothing can be
done other than to just,
we're so deeply en entrenched
in the kind of belly of it.
What's a role?
And what part of what the
question made me think about
was the legacy of critical race theory,
which actually emerges
from similar institutions,
but actually challenges,
contests and says,
what you're doing is not,
it's not just we want more from it.
We have a far, far more expansive sense
of what education is for
than the parochial mediocre
education you're providing us.
So could you just as we like,
help us think maybe about
from these sites, right,
what those lessons might teach us
about the connections we can make.
Is there a CRT lesson in here for us?
- Okay, Danny.
So you have me trying to tell
a story in two minutes, right?
So here's what,
where I'll start and hopefully finish
with just a note on Tyre Nichols.
You know, one way in which I think
those of us who are concerned
about the trajectory
of the attack on education
and those who are doing it.
One thing that we agree on
is that education has been
and continues to be the key
to transforming the society.
The only difference is
a normative difference.
We believe in the transformation,
and they don't, right?
But we converge on the
absolute critical dimension
of having access to education
and the production of
new knowledge, right?
So I will say then in
about public education,
I know you guys have your debate about it,
but public education was
the product of freed people
during reconstruction, right?
The first thing they wanted to vote.
The second thing they
wanted was education.
It was the thing that,
was the second thing that
redeemers went after.
First they went after the vote,
and then they burned
down the school houses.
That relationship continues to this day.
So the same states that
have these memory laws
and the efforts to suppress education
are the same ones that
are trying to suppress
the right to vote.
We need to learn about what
those connections tell us
about the significance of institutions
that produce the knowledge that we need
to sustain our democracy, right?
So these things have always
been one and the same.
They've always been connected.
All sides or both sides
of this agree to it.
We realize that there's a connection
between a past that said
if you taught an enslaved person to read,
you could be punished.
And if you were that enslaved person,
you could be punished with death.
That tells us that a
status quo is maintained
by denying people who
are at the bottom of it
the capacity to read the
situation, to be literate about it,
to be able to change it.
So that's a continuing dynamic
that we are still in the middle of,
and we need to be able
to pull those lessons
to the forward moment.
Now the reality is that
we have made strides
as, you know, David has said.
These institutions do not look the same.
This does not look like the
same I'm sure 30, 40 years ago,
it wouldn't have looked like this, right?
That is the product of pressure.
That is the product
of imagining the
university being different.
That is the product of bringing
our political material,
our political connections,
all the things that make for
transformative possibilities
to bear.
That is what happened.
Critical race theory is a product of that.
It comes from ethnic
studies as applied to law.
It comes from African American
If we realize that the
inequalities that we face
are not the product of our own deficits,
but deficits in our structures,
in our institutions,
then the question is,
well how do the different
disciplines that we are in
contribute to that?
And so we went into law
school asking that question.
How does law contribute to naturalizing
an unequal status quo?
First by depriving individuals and groups
of the ability to change that
and then rationalizing
saying that it's colorblind,
so it's okay.
So effectively the story
of critical race theory
is the story of the institution
of education written large.
Young people coming
into these institutions
with a different idea
about what the purpose of education is,
a different idea about what the mission
of the institution is, and
a lower level of tolerance
for the failure to get what
they think they deserve
out of these institutions.
So I wanna suggest that the story
of African-American
studies and ethnic studies
and queer studies and
critical race theory,
that is the history that
we have to bring to bear.
Those are the stories that tell us
that we don't have to accept
the limited parameters
of the education that we have.
It tells us that when we coordinate,
when we make our demands,
and when we believe they're legitimate,
and we come up with alternative ways
of delivering knowledge and information,
we actually change things.
So now this is the pushback against it.
With every transformative
moment there is a pushback,
and they're just happening quicker.
So 2020 transformative possibility,
2022, 23, massive pushback.
Once we understand that this
is all part of the dynamic,
we don't have to accept this
is just the way things are.
This is the way things
have been made to be.
And we yes can do something about it
because we already have.
- Yeah, great. (audience applauding)
I'm so grateful for this discussion.
We should announce
there's another webinar,
web event next Wednesday
where mainly the same themes.
- Yes, and people.
Gonna be a road show.
- Yeah, but to invite you to that.
To remember, APF is at the center
of driving these campaigns,
The Anti-racist Teaching
and Learning Collective
in Connecticut, Students
for Educational Justice.
A beautiful bookstore in New
Haven, close to our campus,
Possible Futures.
There are resources here, yeah.
Nothing has to be be done whole cloth.
Everybody please join me in
thanking our amazing panel.
(audience applauding)